hey how's it going man you hear me
yeah i hear you loud and clear how you
doing how's it going hey
um i'm 26. um i've kind of gone down
like a red pill
mgtow baptism over the past two years or
so um i'm a
i'm a christian reformed baptist i've
got some religious um
tint to my views as well obviously
obviously as a christian
um you know i have expectations you know
from my family and some people in my
church so obviously i'm
not falling you know by being mgtow
which causes some conflict anyway
that's i don't want to get too broad
really my main question is
um a lot of times when i uh
you know talk to blue-pilled people who
are who actually want to have a
conversation about red pill views and
are just immediately dismissive um
a lot of times one of the one of the
often um
i don't know stated counterpoints that
comes up that you'll hear is people will
say well you know
what you're saying some of it makes
sense but um
you know don't you need to apply these
criticisms
to uh both so if i bring up like
hypergamy for example right if i say
if i explain why what hypergamy is and i
say programming doesn't care they'll say
well
yeah like i can see what you're saying
but you know men have
men have similar qualities you know
they're looking for like the the top
females not so really you know don't
isn't this why are you applying it to
women so strongly shouldn't you apply it
to both men and women so
i guess what are you talking to when
you're having this conversation
well um just multiple people but like
okay like just today i
was just with a friend of mine he's a
colleague of mine we were having beers
and he's in a new relationship and he's
he's he's blue pill
uh more or less um are you trying to
regulate these guys because you want
them to join your club
no no we were talking about we haven't
talked like this guy
specifically we hadn't talked in a long
time and he was talking his relationship
and he asked me what i was doing i just
kind of was just giving him my you know
yeah i've just
i don't know i've kind of been you know
blah blah blah and we
i brought up i think i brought up like
the term red pill or something like that
he was like oh i've heard that before
and we start talking about
it and when we when i kind of got to
explaining you know some of these things
he was like yeah he's like i think you
need to apply
that ideology more broadly to both sexes
instead of just focusing on women or
whatever
um i don't really go out trying to
preach the preacher baptized but yeah so
so generally speaking you don't want to
waste any time trying to
initiate people that don't want to be
initiated right the teacher is going to
appear when the student's ready
the student's ready when they have their
heart broken when they get cheated on
when they go through the divorce machine
when
they get bad results with women time and
time again
um when you start talking to like one of
your average joe friends about
red pill concepts like you know
hypergamy and then they start you know
feeding you some crap well it doesn't
just apply to women you know why does it
know what you know why can't it also
apply to men it's like okay
you might as well like like talk to this
mug okay
like just just have a conversation with
this mug and said you're going to get
in fact get this mug and give it to your
friend
well no i mean like but these are all
the teespring store below right
yeah if you don't if you don't think
it's applicable to the show we i think
you can be on go but i mean i would just
want to like
you know as i mean i'm still learning
you know i'm 26 i'm like two years into
this kind of journey i guess i'm just
saying like what
i mean do you have like what is the
generalization right now let me ask you
that question
why am i mgtow yeah um i basically was
at like a mental low point a few years
i've never been like a long-term
relationship but i've been was that kind
of mental low point like um a few years
ago and
i just i did a lot of self evaluation
and um i had been like rejected by this
girl that i liked and you know i was all
like oh this is the worst you know my
you know i
can't you know i'm gonna be alone blah
blah i basically came to realization
after
diving into some some mgtow content and
some um you know
what do you watch as far as mgtow watch
you
watch uh coach or watch um red pill
men's health um
i did read some books i want to read
your book i haven't gotten it yet i read
the manipulated man
you know valar's manipulated man all
this stuff all this to say i basically
came to this this realization point
where i was like oh okay
everything i've ever done my entire life
for for any reason was to
please a woman whether it be my mother
or the girls my age around me i've never
done one thing to improve myself
ever for me and so i just kind of got
you know oh
okay so i just so i so i delete all my
dating apps stop
you know pursuing women and just kind of
like wearing this kind of personal
journey to just be my to be me
and try to like improve myself for
myself i guess but i mean like you're in
your 20s like you know this is
like like these are the years for you to
lay the foundation for your life these
are the years to bang these are the
years to understand women these are the
years to kind of like go through all
that because
if you're a christian guy and i assume
you want to have a family and children
you need to have your head squared away
properly when it comes to women you know
when you want to cross that bridge
and you know sitting around being
a man going his own way doing nothing to
kind of like remedy all these things
watching more
mgtow con like the sort of stuff that
i'd say that
you'd be better off watching and reading
would be
rollo's books book book one and two you
know specifically
in fact you know since you're a man of
god you know read his fourth book it
just came out it's on
religion um i'm sorry who is this i'm
sorry rolo tomasi
okay okay he's got a book series called
the rational mail
stop stop watching the mgtow contest
i'm not a mgtow content creator it's
you know it's a place that you can visit
take a break from stuff
uh regather and then you know you build
yourself
back up from there um but
i get that you know you've been you've
been hurt and you've got to work on some
of that stuff
but you've got to you've got to lead by
example like
this friend of yours you're talking
about hypergamy with and it's like hey
let's have this conversation he wants to
argue with it like
you won't have these like a real mgtow
doesn't have conversations with with
with guys like that right they just
choose themselves first
they'll go and make decisions on a daily
basis that that
that are surrounded with mental point of
origin just
stay away from anything negative that's
like oh look at this article and see
you know women aren't aren't worth it
and this is why you should just stay
mgtow um like i said it's a place to
visit
okay well you say you have to build
yourself back up after that
you say that but don't don't i mean i've
heard you a spouse on this channel on
your podcast that you don't believe that
that marriage is a good investment for
men pretty much at all i mean is that
true
no i don't think okay so i mean that
that's that's you're saying like oh
you're a christian so you want to have a
family but what i'm
what i'm saying is that i'm kind of
trying to steer myself away from that
and kind of trying to
not make that a goal which you know i'm
saying i'm trying to make that not like
not my goal is to i don't want to yeah
so ethan the the clarity that you need
you will
you will get from my book you'll get
from rollo's first two books
i haven't read his fourth book yet on
religion but
get but but get rolos rational male
series
and read my book the unplugged alpha
come back on the show in a few weeks
once you've gone
gone through all that and then asked
some more questions that appreciate your
time thank you
you